السلام عليكم واهلا بكم في موعدنا اليومي
حول
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
غزه امام اعين ذوي بعض المحتجزين في غزه
ومع تعالي اصواتهم المستهجن اثناء كلمته
في الكنيست قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو ان اسرائيل لن تتمكن من
اطلاق سراح الرئ المحتجزين في غزه بدون
ضغط عسكري نتنياهو تعهد في كلمته ايضا
بمواصله الحرب في قطاع غزه
وبتعمص حتى تحقيق اهدافها حسب تعبيره كما
اكد انه بحاجه الى المزيد من الوقت وان من
غير المسموح ايقاف الحرب قبل تحقيق انتصار
حاسم كما قال اما زعيم المعارضه يائير
لبيد الذي كان قد دعى لجلسه الكنيست بشان
المحتجزين فقد انتقد اداء الحكومه في
ملفهم وقال انها لا تفعل ما يكفي حتى
يعودوا من غزه ابيد دعى ايضا الى وضع
اعاده المحتجزين كاولو مطالبا مجلس الحرب
بوضع ما سماه منحا اسرائيليا لصفقه تبادل
من اجل اطلاق سراحهم وعود ومطالبات تقبلها
او تقابلها على الارض مصاعب مختلفه بدءا
من تعقيدات الميدان الذي تكبد فيه
المقاومه الق الاسرائيليه خسائر مستمره
رغم تصعيد قصفه الجوي والمدفعي غير
المسبوق في جنوب ووسط غزه مؤخرا مع تركيزه
على مناطق سبق ان اعلن السيطره عليها من
قبل وصعب من نوع اخر تواجه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي نقلت رويترز عن وزاره
ماليتها ان تكلفه الحرب ستبلغ على الارجح
ما لا يقل عن 14 مليار دولار في العام
المقبل كما اضافت ان الحرب تؤدي الى
مضاعفه العجز المالي ثلاثه اضعاف حجمه
الحالي مع توقع لاستمرار القتال حتى
فبراير اباط
المقبل نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستديو الدكتور لقاء مكي الباحث الاول
في مركز الجزيره للدراسات من خان يونس
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اياد القاره ومن
القدس الدكتور محمد هلسه الاكاديميه
والخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه دكتور لقاء مكي بعد 80 يوما
ما الذي يمكن ان يقال عن اسرائيل ومدى
تحقيقها لاهدافها التي
اعلنتها
مقارنه بما اعلن بالاهداف المعلنه لم
يتحقق شيء على الاطلاق وربما يعني احنا
نتكلم عن اعلاناتهم يعني فقط الاعلانات
الرسميه تدمير
حماس بشكل
كامل جعل غزه منطقه امنه بالنسبه لاسرائيل
حتى اعاده السلطه ما هذا هو احتلال الضفه
يعني احتلال غزه لم يتحقق شي وعده
المحتجزين طبعا عده المحتجزين بالتاكيد لم
يتحقق اي من هذا على الاطلاق والامر
الادهى ان الامر زاد صعوبه بعد 80 يوم تجد
حكومه نتنياهو نفسها امام والجيش
الاسرائيلي طبعا امام ليس فقط خطر حقيقي
بالنسبه للجيش ومستنقع في غزه
وانما التلاشي التاييد الشعبي في داخل
اسرائيل للمعارضه وال والمؤيدين اليمين
واليسار
للحرب ما ذكرت قبل قليل حضرتك من جلسه
الكنيسه لابيد يتحرك
الان الدعوه الان احراج نتنياهو الان
لماذا لانه اصبح الان مسموح له بالتلاعب
بنتنياهو على وتر ال على وتر الحرب والفشل
فيها هذا معناه انه المجتمع الاسرائيلي
بدا ينقسم كلمه الرئيس الاسرائيلي يوم امس
كان التاكيد على وجود انقسام احنا امام
بعد 80 يوم انقسام بالمجتمع الاسرائيلي
حول الحرب هزيمه للجيش واكبر اليته واهمها
عدم تحقيق اي نتائج حقيقيه على الارض
ومستنقع للجيش ومقابل تقدم للمقاومه
وانتصارات حقيقيه على الارض هل هذا كله
دكتور هلسه سيزيد من حده المطالبات بضروره
رحيل نتنياهو بعد 80 يوما الى درجه الى
جانب ما يقوله المسؤولون الاسرائيليون
والسياسيون في المعارضه هاردز خصصت
افتتاحيتها اليوم ل مطالبه نتنياهو بضروره
الرحيل
وفورا نعم ربما اشير في هذا الصدد الى
يعني قراءه المزاج العام في داخل اسرائيل
نصل الى النقطه التي تفضلت الاشاره اليها
ظهور مفردات مثل وحل غزه او لا نريد ان
تتحول و غزه الى فيتنام اخرى او اعاده
صياغه اهداف الحرب هذه لم نكن نسمعها فيما
مضى وربما اشير الى ظهور تيار اخر معاكس
للسرد التي ظلت سائده في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي حتى ايام قليله اقول تيار وان
لم يتحول هذا التيار الى حراك على الارض
لكنه يعني يعبر عن مواقف عامه داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي بدات تتنامى وتعارض
السرديه التي ظلت فائده وتمنح نتنياهو
وكبينه الحرب هذه الشرعيه وكما اشار
الدكتور مكي انا اشير ايضا الى نقطه اخرى
تشي بمدى تعاظم هذا التيار اولا ظهور رئيس
الوزراء رس رئيس الدوله وتجن للحديث بشكل
اساسي في المؤتمر الذي ظهر فيه عن قضيه
الخلاف وعن قضيه منع ظهور الخلاف وعن قضيه
مره اخرى التاكيد على سرديه المعركه وانها
معركه لا غنى عنها ثم ايضا مساله اخرى
قضيه نتنياهو وكلما شعر نتنياهو بضغوطات
في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي كلما رفع
عقيرته بالتهديد ورفع وتيره خطابه مرتين
بالامس يظهر على تويتر في في مسافه فاصله
زمنيه فاصله ساعات فقط يؤكد مره اخرى على
اهداف الحرب لماذا يعود نتنياهو الى هذه
السرديه لانه يشعر بان هنالك حاله في داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي تتحول الى حراك يضغط
مساله اخرى في قضيه استقاله نتنياهو
نتنياهو يوظف الثقافه السياسيه السائده في
داخل المجتمع على امتداد عمر هذا الكيان
لم يقدم اي رئيس وزراء استقالته طائعا
انما كل رؤساء الوزراء والمسؤولين الذين
سببوا كوارث طبيعيه او في اطار حروب
اضطروا الى الاقاله بعد تشكيل لجان تحقيق
وبعد حوكمه ما يسميه المجتمع الاسرائيلي
حوكمت هذه القضايا اذا يعلم بانه في داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي لم يتشكل حرك ضغط حتى
هذه اللحظه وانه المساحه التي يتيح له
النظام السياسي في اسرائيل تسمح له
باستمرار المناوره حتى وان ظهرت اصوات
تطالب نتنياهو بالاستقاله ويعلم بانه لن
يستقي الا تحت وقع ضغط تيار جارف وتحت
مبدا الحوكمه وم لجان التحقيق هذه هي
الاجواء الاسرائيليه ماذا عن الاجواء
الفلسطينيه سيد اياد القاره الكل يعلم
التكلفه البشريه المريره في غزه ولكن
بالنسبه للمقاومه هل يجوز لنا ان نتحدث عن
انجازات محدده بعد 80
يوما الانجازات التي حققتها المقاومه هي
بدات من يوم السابع من اكتوبر حقيقه
ودائما يجب ان نعود لهذا اليوم الذي الذي
الذي بنت عليه المقاومه تحركها لما كان
قبل 7 اكتوبر حول انتهاكات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وكانت مرتبطه بالمناسبه
بالاقصى ومرتبطه بعدم القدره على التوصل
لاتفاق حول اطلاق سراح الاسرى من سجون
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مقابل الجنديين اورون
جولدن جولدن وشاول اورون وما ترتب على ذلك
ان المقاومه على مدار 80 يوم كانت ادت
اداء يمكن ان نقول تطور مع الوقت رغم انه
ما حدث في 7 اكتوبر ليس قليل كان هناك جهد
عسكري ضخم قامت به كتائب القسام استنزف
جهد كبير من القوه القوه القتاليه بالنسبه
لكتائب القسام خاصه الوحدات الوحدات النخب
التي تمكنت من اجتياح منطقه الغلاف ولكن
سرعان ما اعادت ترتيب نفسها في مقاومه
طويله الامد على مدار 80 يوما تتحدث
احيانا قد الجيوش ت تصاب بالانهاك نتاج
عمليات عسكريه متواصله في كل المناطق على
على على مستوى قطاع غزه خاصه في مناطق
شمال قطاع غزه والان نتحدث عن ثلاثه اربعه
اسابيع من المواجهه ايضا في خانيونس وتكبد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خسائر بشريه كبيره
بالامس هناك 15 جندي وضابط اسرائيلي قتلوا
في مناطق من قطاع في قطاع غزه واضطر
نتنياهو للخروج في الصباح والمساء في
كلمات مسجله يتحدث فيها عن النصر ويريد
بشكل او باخر ان يواجه الموجه الكبيره
التي بدات تتسع داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
الجانب الاخر ايضا انه المقاومه تعمل في
بعد اساسي هو صد العدوان على المواطنين
الفلسطينيين وهي تضغط باتجاه تكبيد الجيش
الاسرائيلي خسائر وصولا لاجباره على وقف
اطلاق النار والانسحاب من من قطاع غزه
لذلك هي تعمل وفق استراتيجيه واضحه وقالت
من البدايه انها هي مستعده لمواجهه على
مدار الاسابيع وعلى مدار الاشهر وفي مرات
سابقه قبل 7 اكتوبر قالت انها جاهزه لقصف
تلبيب على مدار سته اشهر بعشرات او عفوا
بالاف الصواريخ على مدار ست شهور هذا هذا
الحديث السابق ل قبل 7 اكتوبر وهي حتى
الان تعمل بهذه الاليه وبهذه الطريقه
وتمنع اسرائيل حتى على صعيد الجبهه
الداخليه بالشعور بالامان كما حدث قبل
يومين في قصف تلبيب وكانت الموجه الاكبر
على صعيد منذ انطلاق منذ 7 اكتوبر لذلك
اسست بتقديري في في جانب الثالث اسست لانه
المقاومه هي القادره على ردع اسرائيل وهذا
اصبح مفهوم يمكن ان نسميه راسخ في الوعي
الفلسطيني والوعي العربي الاسلامي ولكن
بغض النظر عن مكاسب هذا الطرف او ذاك
دكتور لقا مكي كلاهما الان مدعو للتعامل
مع ما يوصف الان بمقترح مصري لم يعلن بشكل
رسمي ولكن الان عديد وسائل الاعلام تتحدث
عنه
هاردز
اسوس بريس يدعوه تحر نوت حديث عن اطلاق
سراح
40 مخطوف او محتجز مقابل عدد من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين هدنه لاسبوعين او ثلاثه بعدها
يتم الحديث والنقاش عن اطلاق سراح الكل
مقابل الكل ولكن مع
اضافات تتعلق بالانسحاب الاسرائيلي الكامل
من قطاع غزه وقف طويل لاطلاق النار اقامه
حكومه تكنوقراط في القطاع لا يكون فيها لا
حماس ولا الجهاد ولا غيرها هل تعتقد بان
يمكن ان تسير الامور بهذا الشكل علما وان
هناك رفض كما قالت رويترز ل حماس والجهاد
لهذا لهذا الامر هو يعني اولا الصفقات
التسويه الخاصه بالحروب تتحدد في ضوء
النتائج المنتصر يفرض شروطه وال زوم
يستجيب رغما عنا احنا نتحدث عن وقائع
اصبحت الان متاحه للجمهور يعني معروفه
للجميع وهي ان ما جرى في غزه حتى الان سقف
الاهداف الاسرائيلي لم يتحقق مقابل اصرار
فلسطيني على البقاء والبقاء هو بحد ذاته
انتصار بغض النظر عن النتائج على الارض
المتحققه باستشهاد اعداد هائله من
الفلسطينين اسرائيل لم تحقق هدفها الاساسي
المتجسد بقضاء على حماس و رئيس
الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه اليوم يصفه بانه
هدف غير واقعي وبان اصلا طرحه منذ البدايه
كان غير صحيح لانه هذا هدف لا يمكن تحقيقه
بالتالي احنا امام معادله معقده نسبيا
نتنياهو من جهه اللي يقدم الوعود ويعتقد
انه الموافقه من جانب او انهاء الحرب يعني
نهايه الشخصيه ونهايه اليمين الاسرائيلي
متسلح باليمين اللي شركاء بالحكم وباليمين
في الشارع يريد
الاستمرار اليسار الاسرائيلي
والعوائل الاسرء والولايات المتحده يريدون
النزول من الشجره والذهاب الى صفقه تسويه
تكون مناسبه لانهاء المستنقع وتكون واقعيه
لكن ل الولايات المتحده اهدافها واقعيه
ولا اسرائيل بالتاكيد او نتنياهو حتى
الولايات المتحده وحتى اليسار حينما
يقولون انه يجب ان تنتهي الحرب بعوده
الاسرء وايضا بانتهاء دور حماس في غزه
ماهي نفس الاهداف الاسرائيليه هذا ايضا من
المعقد جدا تسيره لكن اعتقد انه احنا ما
زلنا في بدايه الطريق لان المساله ايضا
معقده على حماس نعم حماس لن تهزم في
المعركه هذا مؤكد اصبح الان لكن من
المحتمل ان يكون هناك خطه امريكيه للضغط
على نتنياهو للخروج من المشهد وبالتالي
المجيء بحكومه جديده تكون قادره على
التعامل مع صفقات لانها غير ملزمه بوعود
سابقه ليس لديها سقوف عاليه وهذه الصفقات
تتضمن استمرار الضغط على القطاع الحصار
الاقتصادي وبالتالي اجبار حماس على الرضوخ
بتوالي الزمن لانه الناس في غزه لا
يحتاجون للغذاء فقط يحتاجون الاعمار
الاعمار مرهون باليات سياسيه معينه
بالتالي اعتقد ان هذا هو ما سيجري في
المستقبل لكن الان في اللحظه الراهنه هو
هدنه لاسبوعين تسمح
بوقف اطلاق النار في المستقبل القريب
واعتقد ان هذا هو ما سيسري لكن طرح الشروط
للمستقبل هذا يجب ان ينتهي من اي صفقه
حاليه يعني لن يكون هناك تفكير لما بعد
وقف اطلاق النار هذا اعتقد هو ما سيجري
بالصفقات اللاحقه الترويج ل ما ما يتم
تداوله من من خطه مصريه او مبادره مصريه
دكتور هالس الترويج لها في الاعلام
الاسرائيلي رغم انها لم تعلن
رسميا من القاهره هل هل يفيد بان ايه
اسرائيل مستعده
لتسويات ما رغم ما تبدو من حده في تصريحات
المسؤولين السياسيين
والعسكريين ال اللافت بان نتنياهو وكبينه
الحرب كما تفضلتم بالاشاره في بمطلع هذه
الحلقه يريد ان يربط المساران معا في
الذهاب الى الحرب هو يقول قول بانه يذهب
الى الحرب لانه يريد استعاده هؤلاء الاسرء
لكن في التفاوض على الحرب في العوده من
الحرب هو يريد الفصل بين هذين المسارين لا
يريد ان يدفع اثمام يرتبها موضوع الاسرى
على المسار الحربي العسكري الذي يقوده
والسياسي الذي يقوده لذلك هو يرفع عقيرته
بالتهديد ويستمر في الحديث من انه ذاهب
الى هذه الحرب الى اقصاها كييف يستوي انك
تريد ان تفرج عن هؤلاء بمسار سياسي انت او
فت رئيس المساد وتبحث في صفقه وتقول انا
ذاهب الى الحرب والاشارات تاتي من الميدان
يوميا بان الذهاب الى الحرب يفضي الى مقتل
هؤلاء وهذا الذي يضغط في الشارع
الاسرائيلي اسرائيل تريد من
هذه المبادره المصريه المطروحه اجزاء هي
تقول بانه جزء مما يطرح من المبادره
الصريه مقبول على اسرائيل الافراج عن 40
مقابل اثمان بسيطه جدا لا يريد نتنياهو
ولا تريد اسرائيل ان تربط هذه المبادره او
كل الملف ملف الاصل بموضوع العوده عن
اهدافها الكبيره لذلك اعتقد بانه نتنياهو
في جزء مما يذهب اليه هو ليس فقط يبحث عن
انتصار بمفهومه العسكري اعتقد بان هذا
الامر اصبح من وراء ظهورنا وظهور حتى جزء
كبير جدا من المجتمع الاسرائيلي نتنياهو
يضغط ل يحقق اهداف في التفاوض لانه الان
يفاوض بالنار يفاوض يضغط على المجتمع
الاسرائيلي لال لا يرفع عقيرته بالاحتجاج
يضغط على المقاومه لخفض سقوفها ويضغط على
الوسيط الذي يطرح نتنياهو انه ذاهب الى
الحرب حتى يقدم له شيء شيء معين يصوره على
انه انجاز واعتقد بان تسويه ما ربما وهذا
ايضا تحدث فيه الاعلام الاسرائيلي تسويه
ما تضمن انهاء حماس كمنظومه تحكم وسيطره
في داخل قطاع غزه بالنسبه لنتنياهو وان
اتت في مرحله لاحقه في تسويه ما ربما
يعتقد او يعتبرها انجاز لانه بالنسبه له
التوقف عند هذه المرحله هو بمثابه انتحار
للاعتبارات التي قلناها مرارا وتكرارا
وتحديدا فيما يتعلق بشخص نتنياهو وملاحق
قه بتهم الفساد والفشل وغيرها لذلك
نتنياهو يستمر بالضغط لمحاوله حصد يعني
شيء معين وهو يعلم بالمناسبه يعلم تماما
موقف المقاومه الذي يقال من عنا منابر
مختلفه ومن قيادات مختلفه سياسيه وعسكريه
انه لا عوده الى هذا المسار التفاوضي دون
يعني وجود يعني انهاء لهذه الحرب اعتقد
بانه المفتاح الان بعرض منطقه وسط تجمع
بين الطرفين ولكن هل هل من الوارد سيد
اياد القار ان ان تقبل المقاومه بشي من
هذا القبيل علما وان مراسل اكسيوس
الامريكيه يقول ان الاقتراح المصري اولي
لم ينضج بعد وان اسرائيل لا تمتلك ايه
مؤشرات تفيد برد من من حماس او من الجهاد
الاسلامي في حين ان رويترز قالت بان حماس
والمقاومه بشكل عام ترفض التعاطي مع مقترح
من هذا
القبيل هو هو كمقترح او ما يتم الحديث عنه
انه هو مقترح مصري هو ببعض القضايا يعتبر
ايجابيا على على صعيد معالجه هذه القضيه
او ذهاب الى الى شكل من اشكال وقف اطلاق
النار لكن هناك بعض الثغرات المرتبطه
بفكره اساسيه هي مرتبطه با ادامه وقف
اطلاق النار وانا يكون مؤقتا وهذه او
ضمانات بان يكون او ان يتبع هذه الفتره
وقف اطلاق نار فعلي وحقيقي لا لاسباب
كثيره منها التجربه السابقه مع اسرائيل
كانت تجربه سيئه واستغلتها اسرائيل لاعاده
الهجوم على قطاع غزه مكان ولم تلتزم حتى
في معايير اطلاق سراح الاسيرات وال الاسرى
الاطفال ولم تلتزم واطلقت النار وقتلت
المواطنين الفلسطينيين على الحواجز
وبالقرب من المناطق الفلسطينيه فكانت هذه
الخروقات بمثابه تحذير
لمقاومه الفلسطينيه بانه في عمليه التفاوض
يجب ان يخذ بالحسبان هذه القضايا والمحور
القضيه الثانيه هي مرتبطه بالتواجد
الاسرائيلي داخل قطاع غزه الامر لا يستوي
وقف اطلاق نار مع بقاء قوات الجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تفصل مناطق الشمال عن
مناطق الجنوب وهناك مئات
ع الا النازحين موجين وهم اصلا هم من
يتبنوا فكره عدم الذهاب الى هدنه انسانيه
ويطالب بوقف اطلاق نار دائم مع عودتهم الى
بيوتهم حتى لو كانت دمرها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في غزه وفي شمال قطاع غزه لذلك
قد تكون الورقه صالحه لفتح ملف التفاوض
بهذا الاتجاه وبالمناسبه هو من روج لها
الاعلام الاسرائيلي ويريدها نتنياهو بشكل
او باخر وان كما يعني تحدث ضيفكم الكريم
عن ان هي بالنتيجه بمفهوم نتنياهو ستؤدي
الى ابعاد حماس عن الحكم او الحكم
والسيطره في قطاع غزه حماس لا تهتم كثيرا
بهذا الامر موضوع الحكم والسيطره وابدت
كثير من الملاحظات الايجابيه بما فيها حتى
الذهاب الى انتخابات حتى قبل الحرب على
قبل 7 اكتوبر الجانب الثاني ايضا فيما
يتعلق بانه نتنياهو بال الغالب سيكون
نهايه نيتنياهو قبل نهايه حماس في اي سواء
انتهت الحرب بالطريقه التي ذهاب لوقف
اطلاق ننار او بدون وقف اطلاق النار لانه
عمليا المجتمع الاسرائيلي لم يعد يحتمل
استمرار نتنياهو بالحكم والاصوات اليوم
كانت واضحه في الكنيست وخارج الكنيست وفي
التجمعات المختلفه وحماس بنفس الوقت ابدت
مرونه على صعيد التفاوض والتعامل مع
الوسطاء كما حدث في الفتره الماضيه وهي لم
ترفض ولم يتم قبل قليل عضو المكتب السياسي
عزه الرشق تحدث بشكل واضح وقال انه لم
يعرض علينا هذا الامر ولم نتحدث بهذا
الجانب ونفى ما تداولته حتى وكاله رويترز
وهذا بمعنى انه الموقف المقاومه واضح
باتجاه ضروره وقف اطلاق النار او اي هدنه
انسانيه قابله لان تكون نهايتها وقف اطلاق
النار مع الاخذ بالاعتبارات موضوع اعمار
قطاع غزه واعتبارات لها علاقه ب تبييض
السجون او اطلاق غالبيه الاسرى من سجون
الاحتلال نعم هو هو واضح ان القاهره لم
تعلن عن اي شيء رسمي ما ما يتم تداوله هو
يتم تداوله اعلاميا وقد يكون من من قبيل
بالونات الاختبار الكتور لقا مكي خاصه وان
المقاومه قد لا تكون مجبره على التعاطي مع
اشياء من هذا القبيل مع استمرار الاداء
العسكري الجيد كما يوصف لانه اخر الاخبار
مثلا مستشفى سوركه في بئر السبعه يقول
وصلنا اليوم 18 جنديا اسرائيليا اصيبوا
كما نشاهد في الخبر العاجل في غزه حاله
احدهم خطيره مع ذلك مع ذلك مراسل هيئه
البث الاسرائيليه الرسميه ينقل عن مسؤولين
اسرائيليين
بان نبحث الان في امكانيه نفي قاده حركه
حماس الى الخارج وان هذا قد
يكون مخرج لا باس به لانهاء الحرب اذا
البحث جار عن ايجاد مخارج معينه هو سيستمر
البحث عن المخارج لكن انت كي تصل الى وقف
اطلاق النار او الى تسويه عليك ان تضغط
على الطرفين هناك في اي صراع حاله تسمى
نضج الصراع والصراع ينضج حينما يجد
الطرفان ان الحل العسكري اصبح مستحيلا حين
ذاك جان الى التسويه اليوم احنا امام
قياده اسرائيليه ترى ان الحرب حتميه ويجب
ان تستمر لاسباب جزء منها شخصي بالمناسبه
ويتعلق ايضا بطبيعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
والهيبه التي فقدها في 7 اكتوبر لكن
الاداره الامريكيه اظن اظن من خلال
المقاربات التي تجري اليوم ربما لديها
رؤيه اخرى للقضاء على حماس بدون حرب الحرب
احيانا تكون سبب لتقويه الاطراف التي
تحارب وهذا ما وقع وهذا ما وقع ويتجانس
بعد الجرائم الاسرائيليه اصبح دور حماس في
المجتمع الفلسطيني اقوى واصبح سمعتها اكبر
واصبحت الان مثال يحتذى لكل حركات
المقاومه في العالم اذا صارت الرد الفعل
عكسي اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده تفتش عن
مقاربه مختلفه بالتعاون مع اليسار
الاسرائيلي او مع الاطراف المعارضه
الاسرائيليه وهو لابيد تحديدا هو قريب من
امريكا طبعا وغان بالتاكيد
هم يفتشون ربما عن حل مرحلي يتضمن مرحله
انتقاليه بعد الحرب وطبعا مع خلطه من
المكافات لغزه باموال دعم لتعمير وهذا ما
تريده بالتاكيد ه الغزه وايضا حماس لان
حماس هي من تقود القطاع فبالتالي عليها ان
تدفع الرواتب وتقوم بالاعمار لذلك هذا
ممكن يعطوه مقابل حكومه انتقاليه وان تجري
انتخابات واذا كانت حماس يقول لها كذلك
لكن الفتره الانتقاليه ستطول وهنا سيجري
عمليه الاذى من خلال هذه الفتره السلميه
وبدون حرب الانفاق لن تكون موجوده في اي
عمليه سلميه لذلك انا اعتقد ان الامر فيه
قدر من الفخاخ لكن ولذلك الان نرى واظل
حماس منتبهه لذلك ترى السقف العالي من
المطالب ممكن تنزل ولكن في النهايه هناك
سقف عالي ان وقف اطلاق النار شرط اساسي
بعدين نتفاوض
على الاسرى نتفاوض على على عمليه الاعمار
او ماشاكل على الحاله السياسيه واظن ان
هذا هو ما يعقد المساله بالنسبه لي
الامريكان ليس لديهم وسائل ضغط على على
الحماس لديهم على اسرائيل لكن على حماس لا
يمتلكون ف وسيله الضغط الوحيده عندهم هم
العرب ولا سما مصر وايضا قطر يعني قطر
ومصر هم الطرفان الوحيدان الذان يمكن ان
يمينا على يموه على على حماس طالما شرت
الى الامريكيين دكتور هلسه المحلل العسكري
ل هارتس عموس هاريل يقول نتنياهو وبايدن
اتفق رغم كل ما يقال عن خلافات على الاقل
وفق هارز اتفق على ان يسمح لاسرائيل
بمواصله الحرب على غزه وان واشنطن لن تضغط
على اسرائيل لوقف القتال ولكن بشرط توسيع
ادخال المساعدات
والتقليل من عدد الضحايا المدنيين اذا في
هذه الحاله اي حديث عن مخارج ربما لا معنى
له في في سياق هذا ان تاكد
طبعا يعني المقاربه الامريكيه ل الحرب ظلت
في هذا الاطار منذ بدايتها حتى اللحظه
يعني الولايات المتحده لم تخرج عن سياق
التغطيه الكامله والتبرير الكامل لاسرائيل
وتلقف رواياتها منذ بدات هذه الحرب وحتى
اللحظه ولا غرابه من موقف بايدن وخاصه ان
الولايات المتحده وقفت بالمرصاد قبل ايام
في مجلس الامن وهددت وعطلت قرار يخص هدنه
حتى هدنه في غزه ظلت يعني تعارضها
الولايات المتحده اذا اي وان بدا في بعض
التصريحات الامريكيه نوع من الخلافات
الشكليه بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
لكن هذا مبرر في سياق اي علاقه الولايات
المتحده مع العالم والضغوطات والاحتجاجات
والانتقادات التي تتلقاها من دول ومن حتى
في اي يعني الاداره الامريكيه وحتى
المجتمع الامريكي على هذه الجرائم التي
تجد فالولايات المتحده حينما تذهب الى ذلك
هي تذهب في اطار استراتيجيه ورؤيه بانه
لاسرائيل كل الحق وكل الوقت ان تنفذ
اجندتها اعتقد بانه ايضا منح الغطاء
لاسرائيل او لنتنياهو حتى لا يبدو بان
الولايات المتحده فرضت شيء هنالك شيء ما
يختمر واسرائيل تدرك ذلك وقلنا اشاراته في
انه رئيس الكيان ظهر وتحدث عن منع ظهور
اختلافات واصوات تشق الصف الاسرائيلي
هنالك الشيء ما يختمر وال الاداره
الامريكيه مدركه بانه الامر سيترك
للاسرائيليين وبسبب قوه الاسرائيل انما
بسبب ما يتكبد الاسرائيل في الميدين وكان
لسان الحاله الاداره الامريكيه يقول دعوا
اسرائيل يعني تصل لهذه القناعه لذاتها حتى
لا يفهم بانه بايدن والاداره الامريكيه
فرضت على اسرائيل ذلك ويدفع ثمنه بايدن في
الانتخابات وفي الاعتبارات الداخليه
الامريكيه دفع الثمن هناك ايضا ثمن
اقتصادي سيد القاره اذا كان القطاع مرهق
طبعا ويتالم مع كل هذا الدمار اسرائيل
ايضا تتالم اقتصاديا هناك حديث مثل ما
ذكرنا عن امكانيه ان تكون الميزانيه 14
مليار دولار تكلفه الحرب في في العام
المقبل هناك ايضا صحيفه الجارديان
البريطانيه نشرت عن نقلت بالاحرى عن نائب
مفوض الميزانيه قال لا نستطيع ان نخطط على
الاطلاق لاي مرحله تتجاوز شهر مارس المقبل
اذا استمرت الامور بهذا الشكل هل تعتقد
بان هذا عنصر سيكون له دخل التكلفه
الاقتصاديه ليس فقط السياسيه بالنسبه
لاسرائيل
الاقتصاد بالنسبه للاسرائيليين حتى كاشخاص
هو عنصر مهم واساسي وانت تتحدث عن عشرات
الاف الجنود في الاحتياط غالبيتهم هم من
يعملون في مجال الاقتصاد الشركات في
المناطق الجنوبيه
عمليا اراضي الزراعيه عمليا نشاهد
فيديوهات يوميه من يبثها المستوطنون في
المناطق الجنوبيه يشتكون من عدم القدره
الى الوصول الى هذه المناطق على الصعيد
الاقتصادي الشركات الكبرى ايضا تواجهت
مشكلات كبيره كل هذه العناصر هي تشكل عامل
ضغط لكن بشكل او باخر الاعلام الاسرائيلي
او جزء من الاعلام الاسرائيلي يغض الطرف
عن الحديث عن الجانب الاقتصادي ويعتبر ان
الذهاب الى معركه عسكريه من الصعب الحديث
عن الجوانب الاقتصاديه لكن الاصوات بدات
تعلو خلال الفتره الاخيره بضروره اخذ
الجانب الاقتصادي وتوفير ما يسمى بالدعم
حتى لهذه المناطق وعمليات النزوح بمئات
الالاف من مناطق شمال الشمال مع الحدود مع
لبنان او في مناطق غلاف قطاع غزه حتى حتى
الان طر يرفض عشرات الالاف من المستوطنين
من مناطق عسقلان حتى وصولا الى مناطق محيط
منطقه بئر السباع يرفض العوده الى هذه
المناطق بما فيها منطقه غلاف قطاع غزه
التي تم الدخول لها في السابع من اكتوبر
كل هذه عناصر تمثل عناصر ضاغطه على
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي بشكل او باخر
وبتقديري يزداد الحديث عنها مع قرب نهايه
العام باعتبار انه الجوانب الاقتصاديه
تعتمد على التصق كما قلت مع بدايه العام
العام الجديد والسير حتى نهايه شهر فبراير
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك سيدي اياد القاره من
خان يونس شكرا لضيفنا من القدس الدكتور
محمد هلسه وللضيف هنا في الاستديو الدكتور
لقا مكي بهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد غدا باذن الله بتمام
الثامنه ونصف بتوقيت مكه المكرمه